Memory. It can be both a blessing and a curse.
You’ll always remember that beautiful moment when
you and your family walked across golden sands by
the sea on your favorite childhood vacation. Your
first kiss. The time you discovered your favorite
movie, TV show, or book. But you’ll also always
remember the time you said “You too”, when the
movie theater usher told you to enjoy the film,
or when you first got your heart broken, or the
first time you lost a friend or family member,
and realized someday that
others would be mourning you.
Or that time a giant, unkillable
lizard tried to eat you alive.
This is why the SCP Foundation has Amnestics -
The course of miracle drugs that erase memories.
Whether they’re synthetic or taken from
a giant, godlike eel miles under the sea,
Amnestics are the way the Foundation erases
things that are better not remembered.
But what would you like to forget?
We put that question out to the
wonderful fans of SCP Explained,
and you delivered, telling us about all the
anomalies or anomalous situations that are
so horrifying you’d want the Foundation to
neuralise the living hell out of you after an
encounter. So let’s jump right in and see what’s
better off stricken from our mental records…
Random User said, “For me, it would be Scp-1733,
why you may ask? Well, the overall thought of
being trapped inside of a repeating cycle
where you eventually break into insanity
is scary to think about. I’d get my memory wiped
any day of the week.” And we’re off to a strong,
existentially-horrifying start. Unless you’re a
superfan of the Boston Celtics and the Miami Heat,
being trapped in an endlessly recursive
tape of the 2010 NBA season opener would
be a memory you’d want to be erased. But man,
that dunk from Robinson? An excellent play.
BioticNinja said, “There’s a lot
I would voluntarily use amnestics
for even without encountering SCPs; what
makes you think I would have the mental
willpower to resist taking a few if I so
much as encountered such a horrid thing?”
We appreciate your honesty. And to be fair, how do
we know that you haven’t used Amnestics already?
You could have used it so many times to delete
so many unpleasant experiences. How many gaps,
black holes, exist in your recollections? Have
you ever gone somewhere new and gotten that
nagging sense you’ve been there before? Perhaps
you have. Just be sure to like this video and
leave a comment saying “Don’t forget, I was here
before”, in case you delete this memory too.
William Clarke said, “Honestly I wish I
could take amnestics after just watching
this channel's well-executed
depiction of the red reality,
and then reading comments that elaborated
on some of the more graphic details.”
Well, that’s incredibly kind of you, and we’re
equally disturbed by the nightmarish nature of
SCP-3001, the place where Dr. Scranton
has been trapped for uncountable years,
losing his body and mind. Sadly for Scranton
himself, there’s no way we can ever get in
there to give him some Amnestics himself,
but we’re sure he appreciates the sentiment.
False Alias said, “Definitely the Bone hive and
the flesh that hates. I already hate bugs and
disease. Last thing I need for my mental health
is to know those are running around somewhere.”
While Amnestics will solve a secondary encounter
with the Bone Hive earwigs or the Flesh That
Hates, we’re sad to tell you that if you are the
victim of either of these anomalies, no amount of
amnestics will soften the swirling void of horror
your life will soon become. Though it might be
funny to see a horrific Flesh Monster stumbling
around and wondering where it left its car keys.
True Void Chaos said, “SCP-1762, that was
one of the few SCPs that brought me to tears,
and despite having never met them
I really miss those dragons.”
Thanks for reminding us about
that one, True Void Chaos.
Now we’re feeling sad again too…
Oh god, where are the Amnestics!?
Sarah Jamesina Sarah said, “I feel like I’d use
those if I ever participated with the “desire
camera.” I don’t think I have any dark secret
desires or that I’m evil or anything like that
(although the possibility of being shown
my inner shadow has crossed my mind,)
I worry that seeing my “true desire”
might make me too narrow-minded.”
I’m sorry to tell you this, Sarah, but
we’ve already played out this scenario.
We took a photo of you with the
Desire Camera, and you were so
utterly disturbed by the horrifying nature of
your true desire, you immediately requested
Amnestics. But we still know what you want, and
we’re considering drafting a restraining order…
Frost King said, “The Yule Man is one of the SCPs
that have given me chills to even think about.
If it was real, I might have to
choose ignorance on this one boys.”
Now this is a dangerous one. After
all, when the winter months draw in,
and you’re settling down to enjoy the Christmas
Season, you might notice strange noises in your
attic. Funny smells coming from outside your
house. Darting shadows on the yard. The feeling
that you’re being watched. Maybe you’ll just try
to push those feelings down and enjoy the holiday,
because you don’t know about the
danger lurking - Until it’s too late.
Ross Albatross said, “I'd want to
forget about the bowl of soup from dad.
The emotional triggers I personally have, as
someone who lost their father as a kid, run deep.”
We’re incredibly sorry to hear
that, Ross, and we hope you’re
able to find peace - or something close to
it - someday. Losing someone is never easy,
and we hope you have friends and family
in your life there to support you.
Jay Lego Ninjago said, “The Maybe There
Monsters. Their idea even gives me chills.
Monsters that can harm you yet you are the only
one able to see them. Also, scp 2508, a house you
can't leave until you die that has happened
to many foundation workers including 05-7.
The idea of being trapped forever in a place
without any human contact just creeps me out.”
Both are indeed extremely disturbing concepts,
and could be things you’re eager to forget. But
sometimes it’s best to keep those frightening
memories for your own safety. To quote Rafiki,
the past can hurt, but you can either run from it
or learn from it.
SuitoSpy said, “While I feel like many
people will go with better known SCPs,
I would have to go with SCP-1981. Seeing that
tape would be a scary thing to have to remember,
and personally, I would want to
rid of it as quickly as possible.”
Interestingly, the aides of Ronald
Reagan himself also thought it was
best to give him amnestics after seeing the
Ronald Reagan Cut Up While Talking tape,
but because they didn’t give him the proper
amount, it wound up destroying his mind. So yeah,
we suppose the moral of the story
is to use amnestics responsibly.
Juan Pereyra said, “As Much as i love 682 as a
fictional monster, the mere idea of a life-hating
violent hyper-adaptable and unkillable
atrocity would just be too much to bear.”
If it makes you feel any better,
given how much he hates everyone,
SCP-682 would probably take an
amnestic to forget you, as well.
Max Powers - the name you love
to touch - said, “I think just
watching what happens to the D class on a
daily basis would make me want to forget.
So many of those deaths would
be very traumatic to watch.”
That is incredibly true. Despite
the fact that many of the D-Classes
are themselves violent criminals, the way the
Foundation treats them is undeniably inhumane
and horrific. While it’s easy to make a “greater
good” argument about all of their terrible fates,
as an empathetic human being, it can’t be easy
to watch all this play out again and again.
KingMe131 said, “I'd probably go with
something like the Sarkicist cultists.
If I were to encounter them I'd probably be
close to death cause I love our evolution and
growth with tech and those guys would probably do
all sorts of twisted things to me before the SCP
foundation can stop it or anything involving the
children of the scarlet king for similar reasons.”
An interesting thought: Sometimes, encountering
groups of interest can be even more frightening
than encountering the anomalies themselves.
Sarkicists will twist your body into the most
nightmatish configurations imaginable, and
the Children of the Scarlet King might use
dark rituals to impregnate you with
more of their dark deity’s progeny.
So… Yeah, both of these call
for some sweet, sweet amnestics.
Jean G said, “I feel like I wouldn't
really ever submit myself to amnestics.
I have a really morbid curiosity that makes
it so the more awful of a thing I see,
the more I want to understand it. So yeah,
an MTF member is probably gonna have to stick
me or else I'd become a paranoid lunatic
trying to figure out how Anomalies work.”
Once again, we appreciate the
honesty and self-awareness.
It’s very possible the Foundation would somehow
trick you into undergoing amnestic treatments
so your investigations don’t become a thorn
in their side. And failing that, they might
just do things the old fashioned way and send
an MTF hit-squad to silence you permanently.
Yeet Yeeter said, “I feel as if
having an encounter with SCP-087,
since the only three documented cases
have left the class d prisoners in a
state of shock or never to be heard of again.”
Another very wise choice.
SCP-087, and more specifically,
the entity hiding within
this bottomless staircase,
leaves even its surviving victims in a state of
permanent catatonia. Hopefully, amnestic treatment
would allow you to regain your faculties and live
something resembling a normal life afterwards.
Richard Womack said, “096,
I'm curious if the application of amnestics in
a timely manner would quell its murderous rage.”
The SCP Foundation has been hoping to find this
out for some time now, actually. If you have
SCP-096 coming after you, then you may as well
take an amnestic. If it works, awesome! If not,
at least you’ll spend a few minutes in a state of
sweet blissful ignorance before being torn apart.
Joaquin Palacios said, “For me the Panacea SCP,
mostly so that way I don’t live with the
guilt of knowing that there is a way to
prevent death from illness or injury,
even if there is no non-anomalous cure.
In short, if I knew about the Panacea, I would
go mad trying to figure out a way to obtain it.”
Now this is an interesting one. So many
people are sadly suffering from diseases
with no non-anomalous cure, and if
the Panacea was ever made public,
it would surely become a kind of El Dorado for
many suffering or wishing to profiteer from it.
Wars would be started. People would turn
on each other. The hunt would be endless
and all-consuming. Perhaps it would be better
to forget than to taunt us with false hope.
Rahma Shifa said, “SCP-4975. I'm definitely gonna
need amnestics after hearing about that
absolute terrible excuse for an SCP.
It's just so disturbing. If you don't know what
SCP-4975 is, then save yourself the trouble.
Don't go searching about 4975. You'll
regret it. Don't say I didn't warn you.”
Well, personally, we don’t think
there’s that much to worry--
Wait, does anyone else hear that?
Huh, I don’t remember if I brought a clock in
here. Must be a side effect of the amnestics…
Dischord Nation said, “Scp 023: The
Black Shuck is one that comes to mind.
Maybe the amnestics can
cancel the anomalous effects.”
There’s only so far you can try to outrun fate.
If you look into the eyes of the Black Shuck,
either you or a family member of
yours is doomed to die. You can make
yourself forget if it would bring you some
comfort, but it will happen all the same…
Hon Guy said,
“I’d say SCP-106, if by some miracle I survived
his pocket dimension relatively unharmed.”
If you did, by some miracle, manage to survive
being trapped in SCP-106’s horrific pocket
dimension, it’s unsurprising that
you’d need some amnestic therapy.
Though it would leave you wondering why
you’ve got all those scars, and missing limbs,
and missing eyes, and missing teeth. The Old
Man certainly leaves his mark on his… friends.
Norbies said, “I’d probably take amnestics from
seeing SCP 2030 (which I think is laugh is fun)
It just has so many disturbing episodes
that would make me want to forget it.”
What!? That’s ridiculous! Why would you ever want
to forget any classic episodes of Laugh Is Fun?
That show is hilarious. Especially
the Margaret Thatcher episode!
Some people just have no sense of humor…
Darkmega5 said, “That one fish that
can hunt you from any body of water
if you know about it. Can’t get
hunted if I forget about it.”
SCP-1128, also known as the Aquatic Horror,
is the one thing more likely to give you
hydrophobia than contracting rabies. And
amnestics is believed to be one of the few ways
you might be able to escape its jaws of death.
Still, you probably won’t want to spend
some time at the local pool any time soon.
GamingwolfZJ said, “If I survived the
encounter, I’d definitely give myself
amnestics if I encountered SCP 3166. The idea of
getting attacked by a guy dressed up as an overly
obese ginger cat while grabbing rotten lasagna
from its gullet just to shove it into my own
is an image I would definitely use SCP
Foundation Certified Brain Bleach for.”
Look, Gaming Wolf, I get that almost being force
fed human flesh lasagna until you die by a mutant,
commercialized homonculus of a popular comic strip
character is a traumatic experience
that will leave you shaken up,
but is that any excuse to fat-shame
Garfield? Come on now, let’s stay civil here…
8-Ball Gaming said, “If I saw someone
being forced through SCP-957’s chest
cavity then I would literally
become a Class-D to unsee it.”
Suit yourself, buddy. I actually think
it’s an extremely entertaining sight.
To each their own, I suppose.
Loot pad67 said, “Being in 3008.
It's such a terrifying thought that I would
much prefer leaving it to my fantasy.”
Being trapped in the Infinite Ikea
is a truly terrifying thought,
and one you might want to forget after
escaping. That being said, being trapped
in a regular Ikea is also pretty terrifying. You
can really lose a whole saturday trying to find
a new desk in that garish, Swedish, flat-pack
hellscape. Can I get some of those amnestics?
Daniel Jestice said, “The living Legos, so
that way every time I see them it will be
as if it is my first time seeing
them and always make me happy.”
Well, that’s certainly a delightful
notion. We appreciate you giving us
this wholesome suggestion in amongst the
rest of the horrifying trauma, Daniel,
it’s very much appreciated. We’ll give you a
few doses of amnestics as a “thank you” gift.
Izzy Stardust said, “Not so much an SCP, but
a certain procedure we don't talk about.”
Thankfully, it is actually standard procedure to
be given amnestics after performing Procedure-110
Montauk to preserve its high level of
secrecy, but it does have its downsides.
For example, you forget what chapter
you were up to in the storybook.
Nick T Wolf Discusses said, “I would take it
if I met Clef, that guy sounds like no fun.
With the odd way he is, I think
he might be an unknown SCP.”
Sadly, we don’t believe that Dr. Clef
is anomalous, he’s actually just a jerk.
We still wouldn't blame you for wanting to
take some amnestics after meeting him, though.
Grand Wyrm said, “Well to be honest I would use
it after watching a good movie or show to
watch it again, the same goes for books.”
That’s a fascinating approach. For what it’s
worth, there are a lot of wonderful movies,
shows, and books out there - and a lot of
wonderful YouTube videos here on SCP Explained.
You might be limiting your scope by repeatedly
wiping your memory and consuming the same pool
of media again and again in perpetuity. But then
again, maybe you’re already stuck in that loop,
and any good media you discover and enjoy
in the future is just something you’ve seen
and enjoyed, potentially hundreds
or even thousands of times before.
Aren’t amnestics a little creepy like that?
And there you have it, folks,
some of your weirdest, wildest,
and most traumatic suggestions for all
the anomalies worth forgetting - Because
remembering is just too painful. Thank
you for sending in your thoughts,
and if you think we missed any, please let us
know down in the comments - And keep an eye on
our community tab for more chances to take
part in the next community response video!
In the meantime, we’ll… Uh… I’m sorry,
what are we doing here again? I’m getting so
forgetful these days, might be my medication…
Now go check out “SCP-049 - What Actually is
the Pestilence? The Plague Doctor Questions and
Theories” and “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture of Shy
Guy in Space? The Shy Guy Questions and Theories”
for more questions and answers
from the SCP Explained community!